today
we are talking about
bonding between molecules
now we have talked a lot about bonding
within molecules
right and that got us to saying things
like well you can use electronegativity
for example and say
i got an ionic bond all right
or i've got a nonpolar covalent bond or
i've got a polar covalent bond but today
what we're gonna do is talk about how
these molecules how these molecules
bond together what sorts of interactions
can they have
and those are really important right so
so that's going to be the topic now if
we just get started with what we know
what's up there right well there's ionic
so let's say
i'm going to i'm going to fill this in
bond
a model you'll see what i mean i'm going
to draw a little cartoon the
attraction how it's attracted uh the
energy range
and an example right so for ionic bond
we got ionic ionic
okay and here we go watch this plus
and minus there's my model
okay and the attraction here well we'll
get a little specific it's a cation
and an anion and we know that that's
gonna go like coulomb's law right so the
attraction the energy
not the force the energy will go like
one over r
roughly uh now what is the energy well
the energy is pretty wide ranging it's
i'm gonna do this in in kilojoules per
mole since those are the units i have
i'll write that in a second and
an ionic bond can have lots and lots of
range in here and it typically can be
very strong
something we've already talked about an
example would be sodium chloride
it's right there let's put the units
here
the energy units are in i'm going to
write it here
kilojoules per mole
okay now in a covalent bond so covalent
would be here
okay so in a covalent bond remember
we've got something very different we've
got this carrying and sharing kind of
thing
and we've got maybe two atoms right two
atoms like this
and then the charge is sort of you know
the negative charge is sort of floating
around and sharing
those two centers like in h2
or cl2 i'm going to use cl so let's keep
using cl
right that would also be an example of a
covalent bond
and the energy range there is also quite
large 150
to 1100 are the numbers i got the
attraction is shared electrons
shared pair
of electrons and
i'm not putting an r dependence because
for a covalent bond it's complicated
it's complicated there's no it is it is
it's a complicated but it's a very nice
happy relationship but it's a
complicated r
dependence so you can't simplify it like
you can
with a one over r or like some of the
other interactions we'll talk about
today
okay one over r not for covalent
all right now that's where we've been um
here we go here we go look at this
i'm not i'm just getting started because
the thing is
now we got to talk about how these
molecules can talk to each other
and there's a variety of ways what i
want to focus on
first is this thing here that's that
polar covalent bond
that we've already talked about so we've
already got a grounding for it right
but i want to remind you of what happens
right so if i have
let's keep with hcl if i have hcl
that's a nice version of a polar
covalent bond
and remember what happens there is you
you got
a sharing but sort of unfair right so
one of the atoms took a little more
of the charge and so sometimes we
you know represent that with like a more
of the cloud
right on one side than the other but
it's still a covalent bond
yeah but the thing is that and and so
what you're left with like in this case
is some positive charge on the hydrogen
atom
and some negative charge on the chlorine
atom and we did this already we used
these symbols
and we also talked about how that leads
you to
a dipole moment
now what is a dipole well a dipole is
just
the is is just the the description of
what you have in this case where you've
got
two charges of opposite signs
separated by some distance okay
two charges those aren't full charges
those are partial charges
right they're separated by some distance
the distance between these two atoms
and you get a dipole moment and it has a
magnitude
and a direction and remember
just so that just to remind you i did
share this with you in a previous
lecture but you know mu
equals the charge times the distance
between the charge
right so that would be like the charge
would be the deltas here and the
distance between them
right would be this right r um and i
also and now remember the units are in
dubai
so for this molecule for here
mu is around 1.8
d and 1 d
is equal to 3.3
times 10 to the minus 30th
coulomb meters those are the units
charge times distance charge times
distance right
okay 3.3 times to the minus thirds
coolants per meter is a dubai
and again just to remind you because we
did talk about this when we talked about
polar covalent bonds
the dipole moment of these molecules
tends to range
from zero right there
right no dipole to 10 or so
11. right device
now why is this important well because
if you
if you now think well what would happen
what would happen if i brought another
charge
up to the dipole what would happen right
let's say that i bring a positive charge
let's say that i have
that i'm a sodium and i've lost that
outer electron which we know is pretty
easy to lose
if you're sodium right so i'm positively
charged
and i'm coming along and i see this
dipole well it turns out
that as you can imagine i'm going to be
attracted to that negative charge
right so this molecule is going to
orient
in such a way that that i can actually
bond bond to the to the molecule
and and be attracted to the dipole of
the molecule so that is actually another
type of bond
right and we'll call that ion
dipole it's an ion dipole bond
okay let's do this so that i
stay within the lines
all right now okay so what does that
look like well we just said
it's a charge i'm taking a single charge
and i'm bringing it to this thing that
has a shift of the charge within it
that led to these two partial charges so
as you as you can imagine it's going to
want to orient
to form a bond right so let's draw it
that way right so maybe
if i were to take hcl maybe i would have
sort of like a
you know a cloud like that right
where it had its minus and it's plus
there
okay why did i i don't know why i used
dashed lines but there you go
and so and so you can see that that is
what i wanted to put is the dashed line
for the bond itself
give myself a little space right
that's the bond we're talking about
that's the bomb we're talking now it
turns out that this
is an important type of interaction
between molecules and ions
it's an ion dipole interaction and it
has a range
i wrote it down it has a range
of uh 40 to
600 huge range
40 to 600 and the the kind of attraction
is really
not describable in any other way than
what we just described it's an ion and a
dipole
and it goes as one over r squared
if you look at the separation the
distance between these
right that distance the dependence
on the energy on the bond energy will go
like that distance
like one over that distance squared now
these dependencies you can get from
from fairly simple electrostatics okay i
won't derive any of it i'm telling you
what it is
okay good okay so an ion tuple now an
example of that would be
the system that i just drew right so
n a plus
and h cl
okay good that's a different kind of
bond but see
now i could also have two dipoles and i
got a picture for that
well what happened so here's a dipole
there's my hcl dipole there it is with
the negative
partial charge and a positive partial
charge and it's also color coded
right okay so that's cool and there they
are just floating along
and i put an electric field on and i put
an electric field on
and and you can see that with the
electric field so there's my positive
plate my negative plate they're going to
try to align
right these dipoles mean that they're
going to align with the field
they're going to align with the field so
all of those positive
edges are going to try to turn and face
the negative one and all those
negative ones are going to turn and face
the positive one
um and that's exactly what we just did
with this ion
we basically did the same thing here
that's what the ion did
okay that's what the ion did it said hey
come and face me and let's form a bond
but but these these can also be
attracted to each other
right and so i've got a picture there so
you can see like if i have a dipole and
another dipole so this is not an
external field and it's not an ion it's
two dipoles
two hcl molecules right well they each
have a plus charge and a minus charge
they each have a plus charge in the
minus charge and a partial charge
right polar covalent and you can see
that those could line up actually in
different ways to form
attraction and they could also repel
right but overall when they get together
or when two of them get together they're
going to find a way to attract because
they can
because they can't and so that is
another kind of
intermolecular attraction and it's
called a dipole-dipole
dipole dipole
but let's draw this oh it's
and if we do that we have
uh let's see i'm going to try to draw
this
so i've got one dipole i'm going to
stick to that picture
i'm going to stick to this picture but
it's the same as this picture
right where i'm actually using the kind
of shape here
to show you that more charge has gone
over to one side
okay so let's go back to here right and
so but if that happens
then i've got minus and plus thank you
okay and then i'm going to have another
another one's going to want to line up
like this
oh did i do that right yeah and this is
my
this is the bond this dashed line here
is the kind of bond that we're talking
about
yeah those are almost sort of asymmetric
okay now goes in tight now that's a
dipole dipole we don't really have a
better way of calling that either
they're dipole
uh charges interacting with dipole
charges and that's going to give you a
one over
r cubed dependence and then you know if
you've taken some basic e
m or if you do you'll learn this right
you'll learn how to derive these
these distance dependencies so i've got
two dipoles
right because there are two molecules
that have
not it's not a non-polar it's a polar
covalent bond
and those are attracted to each other in
this way and the range of that bonding
strength for two dipoles
is 5 to 25 so it's a lot less
right and let's well if you had
hcl and hcl that would be an example
no now instead of an ion i'm putting two
polar molecules in
right so but this could happen
this could happen um from
an atom from a molecule to a molecule it
could happen from
an atom to a molecule you it could
happen from a molecule
to an atom so so
for for example you know i could have um
if i have hcl and
this has more charge has gone
to the you know to the chlorine side
right so this has my delta plus this is
what i wrote over on the other side
that's my delta minus
and if i have just a single atom i'm
going to put a xenon atom here
well it's just sitting around happily
you know
minding its own business and what's
gonna happen to that
right what's gonna happen to that well
see if if this comes up to
an atom that wasn't that didn't have a
dipole
it still has feelings it still has
feelings
why because electrons have feelings
that's why because it has electrons
so those electrons are in there and it
doesn't have a dipole
but that's okay because those electrons
still can feel
they can feel the dipole of this
they can feel the dipole of this
molecule
and when they feel that dipole they
react to it
they react to it right so there's a
whole nother thing that can happen by
the way it could happen
oh that could it could happen with a
sodium atom
and a plus also is a charge
that that this happy go lucky xena it
doesn't it doesn't know what's coming
but it's got electrons that feel charge
and so you bring a charge to it and
they're going to react to it
they're going to react to it whether
it's a single charge
or whether it's a dipole these are
charges
they're going to change the charge
around that
atom now there's another name for that
and and that leads to another kind of
bond
actually leads to another kind of bond
let's see so i'm going to just
let me draw the cartoon i really want to
make sure you understand this
because this sent sets up the next kind
of bonding
and so let's suppose i take a sodium
atom
and i'll use h2 h gazentite
h i could have been a single atom it
could have been a it could be a nonpolar
molecule
right so this is what this looks like
and now this this is going to
these are kind of walking along happily
and then they see each other
and all of a sudden this is going to
induce a shift of the charge around
those
around that h2 molecule so what you're
going to see is now
more which way is it going to go
which should have the bigger side the
more charge right yeah here because
that's positive and electrons are
negative so now
it's going to look like this now
that was not a dipole it is not a
molecule with a dipole
but it's an induced dipole induced
dipole because of feelings
it comes down to feelings well that has
a name
right that's ion that one right there is
ion
induced see if i can fit it all here
induced
dipole ion induced dipole and i'm going
to try to draw this now let's see
okay hang on uh
okay so the ion induced dipole
i'm going to have a plus charge here and
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
draw the
original shape as what it was
oh boy here we go that's what it was
but then it got induced
okay it got induced and so then once
it's induced you've got like a minus
and a plus happens
all the time it happens all the time
now um the the way that we'll we'll talk
about this in a little bit of a
different way because
this attraction is between an ion by the
way an ion just means an atom
or something lost to charge right or has
a charge plus or binos
remember cation anion
but the ion in this case is interacting
with
what is called a polarizable
polarizable
electron cloud now the electron cloud is
nothing new we got
we we got electron cloud nailed we know
about electron cloud
right because those are orbitals
but what is this thing called
polarizable right polarizable and that's
a very important term so i'm going to
write down
its definition
because you can imagine that if
if i have a way of being attracted to a
nonpolar molecule
by shifting its charge by shifting its
cloud
then how easy was that how much could i
shift it
you can tell that that's going to affect
the bond strength by the way which
is let's see 3 to 15
and has a 1 over r to the 4th
dependence and let's give us
let's give the example that i gave there
n a plus
and h h
okay nonpolar molecule again it could
have been an atom
but it could have been a nonpolar
molecule
yeah no polarizable polarizability
is a very important concept
polarizability
is the measure
because then tight of how
easy
it is to temporarily
temporarily distort
the electron distribution
that is a very important concept
for these types of bonds and for a lot
of other properties and of course for
life in general
how polarizable are my electrons i need
to know
are they just willing to deform from
their their happy orbitals
temporarily temporarily because
if they were going to deform permanently
then you'd have a dipole a permanent
dipole
these are induced dipoles okay
that's important okay
now now okay good so that's an
ion-induced dipole now
you could also imagine you know this
could have easily been
a dipole over here it didn't have to be
an ion
it could have been a dipole i could have
had a dipole here that came up to a
nonpolar molecule or an atom
right and it could have uh it could have
induced the same shift in the charge
density which then allows me to be
attracted
because there's a little bit of a
fluctuation of negative charge there
right let's draw so if i were to
oh so
see the thing is we've been talking
about dimers
but you could talk about what is the
dipole of something
more than a dimer right so this is polar
what about these other things
right so if i look at molecules
right that are polar it's not just about
hcl
right which is that first one up there
but that's kind of
the obvious case but what about ccl4
what if i take a carbon atom
and i put four chlorines those are all
polar bonds and you can see while it's
hard to see but they've drawn in the
dipole moment
you've lost some charge from the carbon
it's gone out to the chlorine atom
there's a dipole moment within each bond
but but now here's
where vesper comes in because
you know these are going to be
tetrahedrally
uh distributed and fully canceling out
so it's like you've got all these kind
of electrostatic things going on
that all cancel out so this molecule is
not a polar molecule
right on the other hand molecules like
nh3
or ch3cl right now this is going to be
polar because
these dipoles do not cancel out within
the molecule so you can kind of use this
thinking there's bf3
trigonal planar right all going to can
all those dipoles cancel
it's a non-polar molecule
but if you take a classic example which
we'll come back to
of say water as a polar exam a polar
molecule
i could do the same thing right i can
take water
which is oxygen hydrogen hydrogen and
you see you got delta plus there
delta plus there and you got some minus
there right
now use it there's a dipole moment
there's a dipole moment
but they and so part of it cancels but
not all of it so there is a dipole
moment for the
net water molecule the net dipole is
what matters
to determine if a molecule is polar or
not right so there's a net dipole
net dipole when you sum them all up and
that's what's going to determine
if this can come along to that xenon
atom right
and so here's my xenon atom just sitting
there
doing nothing and now when water comes
up to xenon
what's going to happen well what's going
to happen is i've got my water molecule
my water molecule my delta minus
my delta plus my delta plus and because
it's
got a net dipole it's going to deform
the atom right and so i'm going to have
let's see make sure i draw this right so
it's going to look kind of like this
delta minus delta plus
and that allows a water molecule to bond
to a xenon
atom it is bonding it is bonding
with another bond which is very similar
to the one i just wrote
goes in tight but it is a dipole
induced not ion it is a dipole
induced dipole
you see that because now i didn't have
an ion i had a water molecule that had
a dipole moment so now i've got my
dipole induced dipole and that's going
to look
oh let's draw it let's see so i got my
dipole-induced dipole so we're going to
go
kind of oh boy there we go
okay minus plus
and then we're gonna now that might be
uh the dipole of say the water molecule
or something like that and then i've got
us another thing that was
didn't have a dipole but it got induced
to have one
okay oh boy i went out of the lines
ah i was so careful but you can't
you can't hold chemistry back uh-uh
no way no way
okay delta plus delta minus
it's induced that's what that means
right
now it turns out that this has an even
weaker
um so this would be a dipole let's just
write let's finish this up
dipole interacting with the polarizable
electron cloud and the value of this
is even lower range two to ten
and the dependence is one over r to the
sixth
and the example let's do let's go back
to hcl
hcl there's my dipole coming in
on clcl i like that because it's got
three cls
why not that's a non-polar molecule
that's a that's a dipole that
induces a dipole in this by shifting its
polarizable electrons around
right and and then it allows there to be
a little bit of attraction
maybe you might be saying but that's so
little we'll get to that in a second
that's not so little that's actually not
so little when you got a lot of it
okay okay dipole interaction now it
turns out
that even and this
is what's mind-blowing you knew this was
coming this moment today was going to
come
i can have an interaction
without any dipole to start with
it's true i can take two nonpolar
covalent bonds
two nonpolar covalent molecules h2 and
h2
and they are attracted to each other
how is that possible well it's what
explains this
i mean we know why does helium argon and
xena why do these have different boiling
points
by the way the boiling point of these
right so these can be made into liquids
and you can boil them right
uh is really different and it's a
measure of how strongly
they're bonded together right so this is
a direct
kind of way of thinking about of
measuring something that's related to
the bond strength so why do these
atoms they're all just atoms
you know they're all just like this
they're not
they don't have this this dipole right
they're non-polar they're just atoms
sitting there with their nice symmetric
charge clouds
how is it that they can be attracted to
each other in the first place and how is
it that they can have such a strong
trend and that has to do with another
kind of force
and um and there's a picture so here's
two examples
there's two helium atoms so that's the
first one in this list boiling point
minus 269 degrees celsius is pretty cold
and there's two non-polar molecules h2
what happens
is that you get fluctuations you get
fluctuations
and and what i mean by that is that just
randomly literally randomly right
because of collisions or thermal uh
energy randomly
one of those could form a dipole
was that i didn't mean it it wasn't my
happy place but it happened
now if it happens and and your charge
kind of goes to one side
even if it's just for a split second
that's a dipole that then if you're near
another atom
can induce a dipole and we know that if
we can induce a dipole if we're here
if we're at this stage we've already got
that covered we already know that i can
induce another dipole if i'm charged
right and so what happens is you get
this kind of fluctuation
that leads literally to a bond
it leads to a bond right
and that is called london dispersion
that's called the london
force and the london dispersion is the
name of
the kind of bonding you have let me just
make sure
okay london
dispersion
notice
notice there's room for one more it's
coming there's more
we're not done we are not done
i can literally take two nonpolar two
nonpolar atoms or molecules
and i can find a way for them to be
attracted
and the way it happens is thermal
fluctuations
this is such an important force and it's
such a strange one
that i want to write down what it is
it's that
non-polar we've been talking about polar
and charges but
nonpolar molecules are
attracted by fluctuations
fluctuations i should say
by dipole fluctuations that's really
what's happening
right by dipole flux so so one of them
gets a little shift and it's
there's a dipole and then that dipole if
there's another one around can induce
a shift and then there can be a bond and
now
um this gets back to something very
important
which is that
you can imagine how
easy was it for temperature how easy was
it
to create that shift right well
that's gonna have to do with your
polarizability
okay and now what okay so what what is
it that has to do with polarizability
right well if um i do have a board here
ha okay
you can you can already imagine if i go
back to this list here
now if i go from helium to argon what
have i done i've gone down
in the periodic table and we've already
talked about this those electrons
that are going to do the shifting to
cause the fluctuation
those electrons are more loosely bound
right they're further out they're more
loosely bound
we've already talked about this we
looked at this in a lot of ways right
whether it's radius or ionization energy
those are if they're more loosely bound
then they're easier to shift around i'm
not taking them out
all right i'm not taking them out but
i'm moving them that's what london
is right i got to fluctuate it so you
can imagine now why
if it's heavier and those electrons are
further out they're more polarizable
right so let's write that down right so
the london
so we're going to get a stronger
stronger london
two reasons one
heavier atom
which really in this case right it's
heavier but it really just means more
polarizable
if it's more polarizable that's the key
that's the chemistry key more
polarizable
more polarizable electron cloud write it
all out but the other thing that you can
imagine with london
right so that explains that trend the
other thing that you can imagine with
london is that
these these uh interactions these
fluctuations they're happening
all over the place and the more contact
i have the more places in a molecule i
have
to induce this to have this fluctuation
happen the stronger these forces could
be
and this is exactly what we see look at
this trend methane
ethane propane and butane all i've done
is i've added another carbon atom oh
we're going to get to these
we'll talk a little bit about orgo later
but for now
look at the boiling points of those
again boiling point being a proxy
for the bonding strength what bond could
they have
none of those only this
huh i got excited only london
because look they're non-polar molecules
they got no charge on them this is the
only way they can talk to each other
but look at how much they talk to each
other now why because of the second
thing right which is that
the greater the surface the greater the
surface
you can have more the more surface you
have
the greater surface
more contact area more contact area
and that's how this bond that's how this
thing works
because you can have you know as as long
as i've got
more surfaces seeing each other then
there can be more fluctuations
right that are happening that then
induce the other one to have a
fluctuation
that then create a little moment of
bonding
that dramatically changes the properties
and look at this this is a little bit
small but
you know these are the so let's you know
go all the way right ch4
c2a okay let's go all the way and look
at this it determines
when you have a gas at room temperature
or when you have a liquid
at room temperature boy is that
important for how we
use these molecules right boy is that
important
it's all london there's no other option
right but that's what's dictating this
trend but it's even more
mind-blowing than that because look at
this this is one
molecule that's identical
this is c5 this is the five atoms of
carbon
and pentane same exact grams per mole
because it's the same chemical formula
but look here
36.1 degrees c is the boiling point here
it's 9.5
why it's all this this is not the ground
state
this is the most stable structure is
here but there is a version that's
called neopentane
it's like a nickname for it there's a
version of it that you can make
that has a different shape and because
this shape cannot come into contact with
itself look at this
you can see it from the red line it's
coming into contact with itself
in the liquid or gas it can't have as
much london
forces london potential so it cannot
bind as strongly and therefore the
boiling point is a lot lower
right this is a lot lower now
there's a little bit of naming confusion
i want to clear this up oh boy
nowhere to go here so i'm going to get
rid of london for a sec
and i want to make something very clear
that there's another word that's used
which is called van der waals okay now
this ability of a fluctuation to happen
which then induces a fluctuation that
can happen no matter
what molecule you have it can happen and
it does
it's always there right so all molecules
all molecules
whether they're polar or nonpolar polar
or nonpolar
all molecules are attracted
by london
plus any other attractive forces
any other attractive forces present
force is present okay so that's so
london is always there
now people interchangeably
use the term vanderballs
and what van der waals encompasses
is more than london
so vanderballs which you will sometimes
see in textbooks
is the van der waals force
okay so that is any
or all added
together this is the combination of
these weak forces
of dipole dipole
dipole dipole
let's see dipole
induced dipole
and london
those taken together those taken
together
you will sometimes see referred to as
van der waals forces
or weak forces but we know more than
that
we know the distinction
we know that london started like this
and then went like this
ah really bad goes in tight
right we know that it started with
non-polar and that there's a difference
and so this is
all about the polarizable electron cloud
polarizable electron cloud that's all
you got
right and this can be really small 0.5
to 40. oh yeah let's just keep with
chlorine two
chlorine two two non-polar molecules
london dispersion and this also has a
dependence of
in terms of the distance of one over r
to the sixth now in case you think
that's small
i wanna show you a little video of why
this matters so
weak forces now weak forces are really
strong we know this
because of mission impossible we know
this
also because of our own students there
was one of my former students rory
and he won all sorts of prizes because
he was trying to be like a gecko
and so he made gloves that were like
gecko gloves and much to the delight
of the facilities people at mit he
actually climbed
one of the buildings using these his
gloves
in case you are wondering it wasn't
actually their delight
um but uh but it really cool stuff so
let me show you just this is like a 30
second video
he found the answer in the sheer number
and design
of the hairs on the gecko's feet
geckos have millions of microscopic
hairs on their toes
of course we can't see this with our
naked eye because each hair is only one
tenth the size of a human hair
and each of those hairs branch down to
billions of little split ends
and they can make such close contact
with the surface that
weak intermolecular forces can begin to
add up to something really strong
turns out geckos exploit something
called the van der waals force
no london london if you think of an atom
as a dancing couple
when you bring two atoms into very close
contact
part of one atom can get attracted to
part of the other
that very weak bond is the van der waals
force
and it sticks atoms together proximity
is the key
but bringing two materials that near
each other is harder than you'd think
all right now obviously
that got me very excited when i saw that
um
because that is how i see atoms and that
is how i see electrons and i saw this
and i almost fell over
and uh and of course i've played it and
i know all those moves i would suggest
you guys
it's a friday there's some good moves in
there
there's some good moves in there and you
can take this on your phone and just
kind of work it out at the club
um and speaking of the club there's one
more thing i got to teach you
because it's that last line it's that
last line
um see um if you go along a trend
like methane silane germany right these
are all attract these are non-polar
molecules
they're all attracted uh to each other
by these van der waals and you can see
that
the boiling point remember our proxy for
the force the the bonding strength
is going up that's what you'd expect
that's because these are getting larger
and they're going to be
more polarizable electrons yeah but look
at what happens
as you go to other molecules this is the
expected trend
until you get here right nh3hf
and that is because of one last type of
bond that is because
of something called a hydrogen bond it's
a very unique
uh kind of bond and so a hydrogen bond
is our last intermolecular bond in
hydrogen bond
right and it's a very particular kind of
bond and it has to do with something
very particular that hydrogen does
look at those boiling points look at the
change i mean
h2o is h2o because of the hydrogen bond
right earth's operating conditions
uh are luckily right here but this is
only
good because of hydrogen bonds that it's
all the way up here and not all the way
down there
yeah so hydrogen bonds are unique this
is the electro negativity scale
and there's something very important
that happens for those three elements
for those three elements those are the
three elements that are in this trend
those are the three elements see
nitrogen chlorine and oxygen
those are the three elements here and
what's important about them is that they
have such a huge electronegativity
and so in a hydrogen bond what's going
to happen
what's going to happen in a hydrogen
bond is they're really going to pull a
lot of charge
from the hydrogen so if you have
so you have a very high positive charge
on the hydrogen but there's something
else that happens
for hydrogen bonding to occur you see
it's the
h with say fluorine
and you have a delta plus and a delta
minus and this is high
this is very high right but you also
have
a lone pair somewhere you've also got a
lone pair
where we know that we have that on the
flurry right
we know that and we got those too and
the bond that a hydrogen bond
represents is the fact that i've done
two things with this same molecule
i've taken a lot of charge off of
hydrogen and created a very strong
delta plus on the hydrogen but i've also
got a lone pair somewhere
that that can bond to and when i have
those two things
which i really have for these three
elements right when i have those two
things
i can make this very special kind of
bond
now um this is what it looks like right
so there's there's a hi
there's an h2o molecule and i want to
make a point here
right there's the covalent bond between
the oxygen and the hydrogen
there's the delta plus and there's that
hydrogen bond right there
there okay hydrogen bond that forms
between the delta
plus and the lone pair now you can see
why water is so special
you can see because unlike nh3 or hf
you see why water had the biggest kick
up
from what would be expected because
unlike nhh
you have exactly the right balance
i've created two of these very strong
delta pluses and i've got two
lone pairs and it all works out there's
no extra lone pairs like here
i've got these extra lone pairs right
that don't don't there aren't enough
moles you know each molecule only has
one hydrogen here it's two and two
that's why water is so special
this bond is so important i know you've
probably heard about it for water but
here's my
uh the example i want to give you for
the club because some of you
might be able to drink ethanol only if
you're
at the right age please of course
um this is the but this is what's in
alcohol right this is the ethanol
molecule
and it has a boiling point of 78.5
degrees again
that tells you something about the bond
strength of this molecule to another
molecule
but look at this that's an oxygen with a
hydrogen
this took a lot of charge from the
hydrogen right so you got a strong delta
plus but you've got those two lone pairs
there
ready to bond to the other ethanol
molecule but look at what happens
methoxy methane is a gas at room
temperature
it's boiled off it's the exact same
chemical formula
it's the exact same chemical formula all
i've done is shift the oxygen in
and so now there's no hydrogen that's
that's had that big of a delta on it
so it cannot hydrogen bond it can we can
london
you know but it can't hydrogen it can't
because the oxygen has the lone pairs
but there's no hydrogens
that have that strong of a delta so when
you're at the club tonight trying out
those moves
go up to somebody and say it's a really
good thing that's not
methoxymethane isn't it really good
thing
and tell them about hydrogen bonds have
a great weekend
you